it's been a little while since I talked
about voter ID of course we've talked
about voter suppression and fraud around
elections many times including with the
great Brad Friedman from Brad blog and
we now have a new Rasmussen Reports poll
which finds that support for photo ID
laws is that 76% nearly exactly the
seventy-eight percent support registered
in 2006 when the latest movement to
scrap the laws kicked off 58 percent of
Democrats believe a photo ID must be
shown before voting and 92 percent of
Republicans and 78% of voters overall
not affiliated with either major party
support photo ID rules Dave Rubin from
the Rubin report is here to discuss
these findings with me yeah you know
whenever I see these numbers I am
immediately reminded that most people
don't realize that just getting a
so-called voter ID is not free and thus
it arguably is not constitutional yes so
there's so much here and I really love
this topic because voting the process of
voting and having your voice heard is
literally everyone uses the word
literally when they don't mean literally
but it is literally the most important
thing that you can do as a citizen right
we have awful I don't know offhand do
you happen to know what percentage of
people voted in our last presidential
election
I mean it's roughly a 50% right yeah
it's pretty pretty terrible I know that
Obama's first go-around in 2008 was
better but in general it's about 50% and
that's just terrible and then we all sit
here and complain so we have there's a
couple issues here one is people just
don't vote and that may be partly
because the voter ID laws but it's also
just because of general apathy people
feeling that the system is rigged
against them it's also because we vote
on a Tuesday which makes no sense to me
because a neither should be a weekend
when more people would be able to vote
or it should be a national holiday what
do you think about that Ackman that's
what I've been saying for a long time
that it's such an important day that we
have to we have to K if we don't have
enough days in the year we have to
cancel
mother holiday because we need Election
Day to be an actual holiday so people
can get out yeah I've tended to agree
with that although I've gotten some
pretty compelling arguments from my
audience when I talk about this saying
even if you made it a national holiday
if voting is not compulsory a lot of
people will just take the day off so
that that you that'll give you some
marginal increase in the number of
people voting but it's not going to be a
landslide so to speak you get some bump
that would actually not be negligible it
would be something because I'm sure
there are a big chunk of people that
just cannot you know if you work 9:00 to
5:00 you commute you don't get home
until 6:00 the polling thing closes at
7:00 like there it's an actual
logistical problem no question about it
and you know the other option which also
we're seeing more of is early voting
hours voting absentee and for the
possibility of electronic voting and
that would have a huge impact I think
because let's face it a lot of people
just don't want to do something that's
out of their routine that is less
convenient and when you combine that
with the reality as printed Sprint
Princeton studies have shown us that
when we think we have a democracy we do
maybe on paper but in reality it's the
legislative priorities of the rich that
are overwhelmingly more likely to be
made into policy you have people who say
I don't really feel like my vote matters
plus it's not that convenient so I'm not
going to vote yeah I mean I think the
system people view the system now is so
broken that they don't even see that why
voting would actually make a difference
so I'm getting back to the voter ID
portion of this do you think that there
should be some national card that is
free that every citizen gets so that you
have to show that when you vote because
I think that's a pretty simple way of at
least taking up some of the X factors
here in terms of fraud and all that
here's the thing it's simple in concept
because you say hey the card is free and
that's it if you don't have a card you
can't vote the problem is when you say
let's go to layer two right how do you
get the card what document do you need
in order to obtain that card and where
can you go to get that card this is
where when the analyses have been done
on so-called free voter ID we find out
well you've got to have either your
birth certificate or a passport right
those documents are not free if you in
order to get a copy of your birth
certificate you may have to get
something notarized if you don't have a
notary in your small town many people
literally now you have transportation
costs to get to where you can get it
notarized if it's truly going to be free
that's a conversation to have there's
sort of a misunderstanding as to what
free means right so so I get that for
sure but I do think you could make a
compelling argument that if all you
needed was a passport or you know
something look we all have some
documentation short of the few of us
that truly live off the grid pretty much
everyone you need an ID to buy a beer
most of us the huge percentage of us
have some sort of ID so I get that there
are some financial reasons why this
could be a problem but it seems to me
that just walking in and I know people
are gonna get angry at me for saying
this but just walking into a polling
station and saying I am Who I am
there is that doesn't feel right to me
either
but let me let me counter that with
something else which is let's assume for
a second that it were a huge problem we
had evidence that that's happening all
the time you could make a stronger
argument around just that argument but
it's almost non-existent right so I and
I totally I totally get that the only
reason I'm saying it is just antek
totally I remember one of the times when
I was living in New York City when I
went to vote and I didn't have to show
ID and that was the first time I
realized I was like wow I just walked in
here said I was you know Dave Rubin but
at my address but literally anyone could
have done it that just seemed odd to me
but I understand that there's no there's
no evidence that this kind of thing and
this kind of fraud is actually affecting
elections in any way and that's where I
start to get concerned when you see
those particularly on one side of the
political spectrum trying to quote fix a
problem that there's no evidence exists
that's a red flag and that's when when
you look at the data you realize Oh
higher voter turnout correlates with the
more progressive candidate winning that
really paints the picture pretty clearly
for me
right that says it right there and of
course the other portion of this that we
haven't even mentioned is that there's
so much gerrymandering going on where
they're literally they just rewrite
districts depending on who they want to
win that that may be a bigger problem at
least at the Congressional level then
figuring out voter ID at the national
level no question about it and that's a
whole other discussion let us know your
thoughts at least as far as voter ID is
concerned in the comments